[Music]
big big night tonight
today is the multi-state primary known
as super tuesday you excited about that
i've never heard sarcastic applause
before
[Applause]
now it's super tuesday it's going to be
followed tomorrow by oh now we're really
stuck with romney wednesday
[Applause]
that's my romney i'm doing everyone's
doing the anatomy
newt gingrich uh apparently very
optimistic about his chances tonight
yeah
this is a quote newt gingrich said that
soon he'll be back on top
after hearing this his wife said please
tell me he's talking about the campaign
she was crying when she said it
well she's she's got a hair helmet to
think of i know
[Laughter]
this week in ohio mitt romney has been
trying to present himself as a
blue-collar candidate
did you hear that yeah he's i'm saying
trying to connect with the regular folk
unfortunately it doesn't help that his
opening line is hello my fellow peasants
ten states are up for grabs tonight did
you know that i'm here to instruct more
than get laughs uh
ten states up for grabs in several of
these super tuesday states a third of
the voters still believe that president
obama was born in a foreign country
yeah these are these same people who
think super tuesday is superman's
birthday
you really do
it's not no oh andy
andy made a cake and everything i mean a
really nice cake
as of uh
as of tomorrow mitt romney newt gingrich
and rick santorum all get secret service
protection
yeah yeah meanwhile ron paul is going to
get a can of mace and a rape whistle
[Music]
cookies in the news excited for snooki
everybody snooki's boyfriend
[Applause]
are you booing snooki or her boyfriend
or just the concept
of such a person snooki's boyfriend
reportedly proposed to her
yeah well there you go
apparently he said uh will you make me
the happiest man on earth or do you
still want to go through with this
[Music]
[Applause]
that's my snookie
his first time he's getting down here
be out of control drink and fall down
this is a uh
kind of nice burn down here yeah yeah
what muscles are these these the old
quads yeah they are okay i don't have
any workout yeah